hey what's up guys my name is hashanah
and welcome to shadow shadow is the game
that I made over this weekend full of
their case you didn't know let him there
is like a 48-hour game programming
competition which you have 48 hours to
make a game based on a particular theme
the theme this time was you only get one
and of course my game here which is
called shadow which you can find the
link to download the game for either
Windows Mac or Linux it works on all of
them you'll find that link in the
description that's actually a lot of
competition like entry page so find the
description there as well and you will
also find the source code there on that
page as well because one of the
requirements of course the bottom there
is of the competition portion of that is
to release the source code so go ahead
play around on that now I'd this game so
basically the idea that the idea behind
this game is your only get one bullet
you are that green little cube that you
see and you are you have to be basically
the the last I guess survival left in
the world here and and and all these
guys are all these red tubes are
basically just an infected cube so
they're only zombies or anything they're
just kind of infected and of course your
idea is to survive as long as you can
now you only have one bullet left in
your in your trusty pistol but but you
can always collect that bullet so once
you shoot it if you miss you hit a wall
you will hit a wall because the map is
surrounded by world if you had a war you
can just walk up to a collectible back
and you have that bullet you can also if
you always if you kill one of them they
kind of drop a bullet it's a bit
different you can see that it drops like
a bull because spins around with a nice
bouncy kind of animation so yeah anyway
I did live stream this entire thing on
twitch.tv for such the China over that
weekend which was December 14th to
succeed for me in Australia and yeah I
mean I'm pretty happy with what I ended
up with it was a bit of a bike I didn't
spend a lot of time on the actual game
because I had I had one goal kind of I
wanted to
want to make sure that my lwjgl applets
actually worked never say they didn't
hum by the end of that I think it's been
about nine hours nine hours probably
about five hours on the on Sunday
morning um trying to figure out like
what's up and I mean I got pretty far
but I just couldn't load any resources
unfortunately into the game so on the my
lwjgl applause did work but without
resources and that was a problem because
I couldn't use textures or music also
the music you're hearing is from the
game of course I might actually put up
the I think it took me like an hour in
10 minutes in total to write the music
for this and to produce it I might put
that up as a video just because that's
like the only portion of development i
can put up since some the rest is
covered with copyrighted music that i
was listening to while programming so if
you guys are interested in that i might
put that up as a video on this channel
but I'm par from that make sure you play
the game the game's main opengl and LW
lwjgl know you guys enjoy it we'll see
you guys next time goodbye I'll put up a
time-lapse soon as well so yeah let guys